[Music]
so and that's what you get news ha ha
submitted by Kay Fung loved David oh
thank you Kay Fong I'm not sure if
you're a guy or a girl cuz it's very
ambiguous yeah but I appreciate you the
way I want to a self set up getting
explicit pictures from men on snapchat
that she decided to pull a prank on one
oh is this Jesus all idealism it she is
from the UK her name is Tara and she's
26 years old Tom
female on taro taro Mountain potato is
this hard oh your blue job is
interesting yeah like there's like a
magnet in between those pushing them
apart yeah they're really separated so
everyone has a different um ribcages all
right isn't that what happens when you
get something too big or something
mm-hmm it could be that her rib cage
shaped is weird or just her boobs are
just naturally more part well we the
more you know for this mod you can't
tell how far apart they are because
there's no cleavage anyway hmm and you
start filling up it doesn't break past
back costly yeah her what does she do
for a living yeah marine biologist why
do you think her hair color is cool
she looks like a porn star I don't know
what she does for a living yeah she does
uh I do believe she doesn't a porn star
hydrolytically that or is she a porn
star congresswoman I believe she's part
of Congress it's not reported what she
does for a living
makeup artist there you go okay makeup
artist good name like God yeah on
apologist I believe so
on a side note I like how you're
adopting to the web see that they can
use a seed I really should I feel like
Joe spirit it's like taking me over
right now I'm about to say some weird
[ __ ] that's it is crazy I know you have
your shoes off your shoes on huh they're
slowly slipping off he's been talking
with his feet Allah oh man
you're right all right Rick and I will
be reading this conversation that she
had on snapchat is creepy guys so here
we go this is the first nefesh you got
which is a picture of his dick and it's
captioned with when do you want with you
when you want to meet and I assure you
response now what were you living do you
live alone
I live with my friend she'll be joining
us oh are you for real
sent me some pics of you girl definitely
I do girl
he says of you girl I'm deaf up for that
go hard I'm og 100m oh oh send me your
post cold I'll check how far you are and
I'll Drive down s of you on a 180 mm oh
you ain't hard you live a South London
I live in Croydon you guys on your silly
name Julia funny Europeans yeah I don't
know a Brill means but Brill see you in
brilliant ah
and then I a kid be emoji like you gosh
what was your friend look like go so
today guys know we're looking at it's
like these screenshots they're like all
over the place so pretty much you send
her like a voice message yeah after
Apple saying I'm near Buckingham Palace
I'm on spur road question mark and she
right can't hear any of that babe text
it and then he says the same thing and
then she says yes babe it is in the
state room you need to come to the gate
what car you in mm-hmm the Buckingham
Palace gate I'm driving a white Ford
Sport and then you thunderous not saying
I'm outside these gates she's at the
booking young college let me know what's
wrong yeah [ __ ] she said bang on the
gate I'll let you in that I can't even
part where I was apparently two officers
just told me two officers with guns they
said state rooms are used by family of
the royal family this sounds a bit fishy
this guy's a [ __ ] idiot I'll have to
park my car on the side and just come
down and you just come down to get me oh
my god the tracks
have you met figured it out that's like
saying okay listen meet me at the White
House since any Oh foot of the Queen oh
my god Miley was an idiot and then he
says is that your mom ah that's a ruby
where are you I'm parked on Spiro
because I got told I can't park right by
the passes for my side
she says the picture he opened the
project is [ __ ] you something too
real why would you do something like
this
it made me drive a waste of fuel money
and waste fuel money and leave my house
and drive all around London take a
screenshot
what kind of sick game you playing at
angry face angry face angry face angry
say thank you to all these angers Isis
you made me drive all the way to an
imaginary place I knew something was
fishy as soon as I saw Bucky and that's
an imaginary plane you didn't knew
something was fishy when you saw you
won't follow through yeah I mean when he
did say it seems a bit fishy hmm but I'm
happy Fargo can you come down and get me
oh okay stupid yeah but she decided
because you're just so sick of getting
dick pics all the time so one big woman
is can she just make her think private I
know right that's a little weird because
you could specifically make sure that
you don't receive anything you know I
mean playing I got getting flack for
this but I don't care be mad all you
want ladies there's a lot of girls out
there and like Big Tex me no no no no
are not like dick pics
want dick pic so they can complain about
so many things they can do to not have
it or not get dick takes like not
letting people they're not following
send them pictures like Dex an option
but girls girls get this sense of pride
when they complain about receiving
dictates yeah command like people are
lusting after many marks and every whole
heart god yeah I know a girl I know a
girl who screenshots or post about every
time any dude says anything to her you
know you can be him/her DM her on
Instagram and it just say hi what's up
and she'll [ __ ] screenshot you like
here we go another fun boy - hi what's
up but she just wants to let you know
people are trying to talk to me oh my
god ah that's like attention I don't get
any dick take more apartment you just
know that's life I gave to you if we
flip through it we're going to see some
losses because if I could receive one
give me one thirty one hand yeah and to
be clear I'm not saying all girls who
complain about big pigs do that but
there are girls who want to be able to
complain about it
I think it's just like that the psyche
of wanting to be wanted as well yeah
that's a deal is it what's mainly like
the popular people you know I mean like
if you're popular people want to be you
or be with you so what I want appeal to
you because that they want to be are
very skeptical right so over that thing
there's a way there's a clear easy way
for you to say I don't want to receive
their picks pluck it yeah you don't have
to it's very easy but you leave it open
hi yeah Mike you there yeah there's
other platforms that people can send me
pics pics on - true but that was net to
push your Italian luck yeah but I really
want to know what she does because
there's another thing that happens out
here
it's these girls who their entire online
life is dedicated to a rectifying
penises all they're doing is posting
thirst traps they get kinda with little
white letters on your nipples everything
sexual all this stuff and then right
after all of that stuff my guy I wanna
see your [ __ ] dick
that's that doing things to it then you
know what you're doing we post that I'm
not saying you're asking for it but you
know what you're doing when you post it
you're gonna get dicks excited and then
some people gonna be like I want you to
see your work but you did this that's a
very interesting way of looking at that
very literally saying you're asking for
it is not really basically not really
I'm not saying you're asking for I'm
saying just be aware yeah like why are
you complaining about it me you can just
block that person or block the [ __ ]
instead of going on these long grants
right after you just post it at working
video for absolutely no reason you don't
get paid
like why are you posting that and then
getting men were you're getting the
counterpart you know what's funny when I
see on Twitter like I specifically
follow this one influencer because she
always writes the same [ __ ] over and
over it's like clearly she's very very
physically attractive and about 90% of
her pics are just her ass and then
she'll write why is it so hard to find a
guy not a likely for who I am
there's like doing it would like you for
who you are I have this person you do Oh
sleeping alone tonight again it's like I
don't know talkative alright she has
initials that are similar to everyone we
do yes follow because of us yeah I
literally followed because of that no
because anyone asked me up it makes me
laugh so hard [ __ ] I just wait say what
you go say today I couldn't take it I
was like this is too [ __ ] much for me
like this yeah I don't know why I can't
find a guy to like me oh my god I had to
unfollow I did you see the guy that
tweet what are you talking about I'm
right here for you baby it's so annoying
it's pretty funny what are your thoughts
on with this girl saying so she's saying
that why is it sexual harassment for
someone to slash a woman on the street
but it isn't if someone sends a woman
their genitals online where your
thoughts on that it is sexual essence I
think it is it is it's not not
selectively this like so what happened
because you can turn this full and if
you wanted to yeah but that's a
workplace and you know who it is yes
sexual harassment you could just report
that to your boss I don't think she
knows a lot yeah I think she's a little
bit confused but it's sexual harassment
actually against the law like sexual
harassment in the workplace gets you
fired but do people go to jail or the
police contacted over that like this
this this sexual battery I can trust
true physical yeah but so I do get what
she's saying because like if you flash
somebody on the subway or some [ __ ] like
that like you can go to jail but it's
not for sexual harassment for indecent
exposure
yeah so corrected if you're in your
house taking a picture of your dick ah I
don't think technically unless you said
it's like a minor it's not the public
yeah yeah that makes sense
but I you can't quote me on that [ __ ]
but yeah no interesting no no I gotta
find out where does it come up that [ __ ]
off real quick whoa JK news fans I hope
you guys liked that video once again
remember if you want to be involved just
submit some article them I'll suck your
dick
now but seriously though there's more
videos up there
[Music]